yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing young Archie who is that nothing
as I it well ok and he plays england
gambar to look at funky oh my god what
the heck is that so and he's probably
going to casually long then right or
what is the deal I cannot give hi I can
also pair that any for was not really
hanging I believe but ok so if i take
here it's going to take on age to wear
ok so 95 loose or something
yeah so the main goal actually after
against such an opening is to take it
seriously a little bit at least I mean
it's complete rubbish but yeah you can
still lose if you blend of stuff and I
mean that's the only hope that black
half so what's what to do now just clean
hear something I don't know and I want
to unpin this this is actually already
better than this position deserves I
mean he has some kind of position okay
so Queen takes he wants to play 94 m it
doesn't I'm gonna have a check doesn't
really didn't really hurt all that much
so I can check on age three or so
outside I know but it is okay and I'll
just drop it back
ok so let's go back
so we'll just see three and let's push
this right back
you know the ship ji Hye Prolia try to
develop quickly and see what happens I
can check their take on c6 it's not not
that great it is probably this and then
go back just have to tell fishes and
okay I'm I would take the early I mean
if he allows it so no 894 discover have
three does f5 I chief FOIA that's not
super convenient to meet you don't
unnatural move idea screen it higher
maybe I should done that immediately
you
Jim you don't want to take this really
mhm to us hanging you should be five
though I think I can play ok ok because
g5 is hanging very stupid huh so I
really I really got confused the end of
the game why is it very fertile yeah
you're winning after move to basically
the angle gamba this is really complete
rubbish so yeah and you're sitting now
I'm sitting in this position so he will
play a 3 I guess or queen g6 or whatever
and maybe I should have played Queen D
for gaining a temple because of the main
threat
so we just must cover that you could
have covered that which will give aid
and then there's got this should check
on v1 so I rather prepare prepare this
doesn't help you do that try to trade
Duke okay then I take it very strange
game black resign yeah that was really i
played this pretty bad because I mean
this is a winning position after move
400 this is completely rubbish and I
didn't really review it fully take on f6
yeah maybe I know this also looks good
but somehow yeah maybe I shouldn't like
here I should have just play 95 I mean
and say okay take it yeah okay it
doesn't it doesn't seem to have a
reputation really what engine finds no
reputation it's just one I mean that's
not bad but maybe maybe it's better to
take on f6 I don't know and this is
already a lot better than
yeah like desserts after this opening
okay Bishop c4 yeah that's a bit of a
computer move 96 yeah yeah I thought
about it briefly but and I just took a
computer just ignores that c2 is hanging
yeah let that might win I mean this is
not bad I made it I made it difficult
for myself here from here and probably
the next couple of moves were not great
Bishop f5 and that makes a lot of sense
covering g4 I didn't I do that that's
certainly better than bishop f3 Nancy
okay the subject and we looked and after
that is it equals I guess and then I
don't know for some real he did not
cover with Luke f8 which is to just do
and now white is clearly better maybe
maybe not winning I could have played
stupid I kept a bad check on c5 check
the check would have been pretty nice
actually winning a second pawn okay then
I we run up the book very very strange
game from both sides okay thanks for
watching